foreign
[Music]
hello and uh welcome
I'm uh Matthew Foreman I'm head of
bioinformatics and software development
at your Gene Health we're a
international molecular Diagnostics
company uh in uh in the areas of
reproductive Health uh oncology
Precision medicine and infectious
disease
and I'm going to talk to you today about
Flex analysis a safe integrated and
flexible approach to non-invasive and
employee analysis
so brief uh summary of what we're going
to go through
uh firstly I'm going to talk a bit about
software in sequencing test workflows in
general the roles of software we're
going to do a quick tour of the key user
needs that we find uh have always come
up in this area
and then we're going to go on in part
two to uh to a study of of an nipt type
workflow we're going to have a bit of a
focus on nipt analysis to see how all
the major parts work we're going to talk
about how we can meet those key needs
that I would have talked about before
a little bit about workflow management
software as well
and then uh uh the final section of a
conclusion plus uh a little bit of
looking forward to what we uh what we
see coming in the future
so to start with
um
the uh software and NGS test workflows
as we really ought to be calling them
these days just software and sequencing
test workflows
so the roles of software
um
for any any chest whatsoever that
involves sequencing
um we have software actually appears in
a number of places
uh most obviously we've got the
bioinformatics analysis section in the
top right corner there
which is right at the end of the chain
after everything that happens in the
laboratory
so obviously we're gonna we're gonna
start with a sample there's going to be
an extraction or isolation stage there's
a prep stage of some kind and then there
is sequencing and then whatever comes
out of the sequencer all the reads that
come from the sequencer need to go into
a bioinformatics analysis
software stage
so that's the most obvious place that
software is going to be involved
um also we have uh I've shown these
things in dark blue on this slide also
we have a lab and workflow information
management system
um which
Cuts right across the whole workflow
including the analysis section so that
integrates all of the instruments
handles all the data flows and provides
tracking for samples and also things
like business reporting and monitoring
functions
there is a clinical data management
function as well we need to get the
patient and Sample the test request and
so with the patient and the sample
metadata into the lab in the first place
and we've got to get the report and the
results back out again to the right
place
so we need a A system that can handle
that data transfer
efficiently and accurately
and there's there can be a middleware
layer as well so which I've kept not
quite in the same blue color uh it's
optional really in many ways the the
middleware state the middle west system
is normally a connectivity layer but
very often the workflow management or
lab information management system
actually handles all of that uh in very
complex environments there will be more
middleware
but as you can see there are quite a few
places that uh the software is going to
appear in any uh lab test environment
um just going on really to the key needs
of any piece of software so whatever of
those functions it's doing there are
some things that it absolutely has to do
so obviously the basic functionality
that the the software has the basic
functionality of the test has got to be
delivered robustly that's always number
one concern and and when uh when uh when
a new system is in a research and
development phase obviously the very
first thing you're going to look at in
feasibility is can we actually get it to
generate the results that uh that it's
supposed to and do it in a robust way
but we also really there are some really
critical needs that that we've
identified uh through the years as well
the
I guess you could say have not always
been at the Forefront particularly when
a a a a new type of test analysis it has
arrived a new kind of system is is on
the horizon
that these things
um you know really we we we really
really mustn't lose sight of all of
these key needs and I'm going to go
through really where these come in and
why they're so important and and the
impacts that they have on the system and
on the process that you use to develop
the software systems
so firstly safety now
this means both patient safety and user
safety in the end when it comes to
software there is so much more to
software development than writing code I
mean all you have to do is to look
through an app store
look at the update text against a
favorite app that you might just be
downloading an update for and how many
of them are going to say bug fixing
um quite a lot of software that
non-clinical non-medical or that doesn't
uh run
um other safety critical systems does
not uh it generally is arguably some of
it's released a little bit early uh and
US users end up doing some of the bug
fixing for the developers or rather
identifying the problems and feeding
back to them
um obviously in clinical or IBD
applications safety is critical whether
you're talking about the patient safety
um or whether you're talking about user
safety with software user safety
arguably doesn't come into it quite as
much as it may do with an instrument
that's that's got Motors and is
physically moving things around but the
the way that we do these things will
always bring into the risk analyzes will
always bring both patient safety and
user safety
ultimately because software bugs in
medical software can lead to wrong or
inclusive results
and the end result of that down the line
could be harm to the patient
they could perhaps not be identified as
needing to go down a pathway that they
other that they should have been or they
may end up going down a clinical pathway
that they that they should not have done
so it's important that obviously above
all else that uh that steps are taking
so that bugs even even if the the
analysis of the system it's fully tested
it's been verified and validated on
thousands of samples and everything
works fine there is still a possibility
that that a software bug could mean that
the system doesn't do exactly as it was
intended to do so it is critical that
that's uh that that's all taken account
of so that's really mainly what we mean
by safety and if we have a carefully
controlled and risk managed development
process for software we can mitigate
these software risks and identify them
and make sure that they are not going to
cause problems down the line
so I said a little bit more about that
last Point actually
um just in a moment
um there is one I guess another little
thing to say on this is that if you
don't have a Control process
there's always going to be a risk that
there are unseen latent software errors
that could cause problems and that's
actually further exacerbated if you have
a lot of soup
standing for software of unknown
provenance
where essentially what that means is
anything that hasn't been developed by
the team that doing the the core
development itself that's developing the
software itself so if they're bringing
in components or libraries from outside
anything they haven't created themselves
um in many cases some of that software
may not have been written or tested with
medical safety in mind you go out of
your way to try and find Solutions uh
that that always do but ultimately code
is written by someone else uh under a
process that you don't know is
inherently risky unless you thoroughly
validate it so the path that has to that
we have to go down if we're not writing
all the code ourselves is to make sure
that all of those relevant functions are
fully risk assessed and fully validated
um before we go any further with them
but what can we do to control all of
these what all of these risks what is a
what does a risk management development
process actually look like
so there is a standard for it of course
there's a standard for everything ISO
aec62304 is an international standard
and it specifies all the necessary
elements of a controlled medical
software development process
um so it covers for example uh
specifying design inputs collecting the
requirements making sure that we've got
everything in mind that the user needs
design and implementation coding the
required testing methods so how do you
go about or how could you go about
um making sure that the software is
tested at the point that it's developed
is tested with other components of the
system and then that the whole thing is
validated together with the final
workflow
and then it also interfaces with the
risk management work and the usability
work that goes on it has interfaces to
other standards in those areas
it doesn't tell you exactly how you have
to go through to go about doing that
because there are there really needs to
be so much quite a lot of room for
maneuvering exactly how you manage the
software development process itself but
it does specify what the minimum
elements are what elements have to be
done at various different risk levels
and ultimately the focus is always going
to be on the whole point of this is on
minimizing the risk of harmful software
errors
um and that any other software error
that might occur if it's not harmful we
at least know what it would do you know
we know what the ultimate impact of that
would be
and in the end what it means is that you
get the highest quality software product
out of that and it gives confidence that
the software will behave only in known
ways only in ways that it was designed
to do
and very usefully it's all this is ISO
aec 62304 is aligned with regulatory
requirements internationally so for
example the the requirements of ceibd in
the European Union
um the FDA requirements it's a
harmonized and various other other
requirements as well it's a harmonized
standard in that way
so moving on from control of software
processes and how you ensure safety and
risk management that way
into
flexibility
because
you know doesn't surely regulate his
software development when we go through
all of those processes standardized
processes doesn't that mean you end up
with something quite monolithic and
static that's very time consuming to
change and therefore probably quite
expensive to do anything with I mean
after all some changes that you might
want to make to a system are pretty
common
arguably they shouldn't take a year and
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars to
do that
so a few typical examples of the of the
changes that uh that we commonly uh that
we have before commonly uh commonly had
come in
um so very often customers will want
different reporting or result formats to
tailored to their own local needs in
their local conditions or maybe their
local regulations
um they may want um
this comes up quite often actually they
may want the software pretty much as as
it is but just a different slightly
different look and feel different
styling that that might mean uh that
they could have their logo in it for
example uh it might mean that they need
to use house colors it might just mean
moving a few elements around in the user
interface a little bit
um there is
often a a request to extract some test
metrics that the system may not normally
give because it's they're not they're
not needed as part of the uh the
validated uh test workflow the analysis
for the fully validated analysis for the
test workflow itself but maybe they're
needed for uh for local reasons for for
monitoring so that post-market
surveillance can be done according to to
the local needs and they may also be a
need to communicate with external
systems that uh outside this particular
test workflow that we're talking about
the next on the list of key needs really
is
usability sorry
that's it that's it right the next is
usability
so
when
bioinformatics software really first
came into being and started moving into
the laboratory it was it was coming in
from a research environment
so
freely available tools had been
developed quite a lot of of we have a
lot of bioinformatics tools that are
contributed to the uh to the community
as with the source code
um written mostly in a lot of them in
research institutions and it's made and
you know we we wouldn't have anything
like the valuable contributions that
we've had to the field and it wouldn't
have been possible to develop a lot of
the workflows the tests that we have
done without those but they're not
necessarily suited to commercial
operational lab environments because
they were normally created without
medical grade code or development
processes
so
that also means that very often there
was a limited level of integration with
lab systems user experience was not
always a focus so a focus on getting a
test up and running to begin with
getting the analysis working is on
exactly that quite rightly it's on
getting it working it's on showing that
it works and that it works reliably
but sometimes the usability of the
interface to actually control that
analysis has not always been kept to
Pace with with just how good the system
itself is
uh and then some rather limited often
clinical data entry and Reporting
capabilities sometimes you end up having
to enter the data into a system via VIA
a spreadsheet for example uh and then
extract the results from a a maybe an
another spreadsheet and then mail merge
them onto a sort of word processing into
a word processing package to to get a
test report so not quite always as
integrated as software could be on those
fronts
um and then also the other thing about
usability is it does have an important
interaction with safety
so ISO
iec62366 is another standard in that
area and that's about designing user
interfaces and user experiences to
reduce the risk of errors and make sure
that safety isn't compromised through
misuse
um usually the outcome of risk analysis
work and user panels user-focused
testing that kind of thing
next we've got connectivity and
confidentiality so lab software of
course does not operate in isolation
the data flow between the various
elements needs to be seamless but it
also needs to be reliable and robust and
secure because we're talking about
confidential information here a lot of
the time
and there are a number of things we can
do by Design and also a number of things
through policy on that front so by
Design we we're trying to make sure that
we used secure data protocols everywhere
certainly absolutely everywhere where
there was any kind of movement of the
data outside the system it's absolutely
critical but in inside a local network
wherever possible we anonymize data that
we store where possible and we only
include fields in a database that are
actually needed
uh and we do things like uh uh develop
parts of the system that will
automatically delete data after a
certain amount of time after a certain
expiry type when the test has run
so it isn't hanging around longer than
it needs to
also you can design in standards to
maximize various benefits of for
connectivity and confidentiality so you
can give away standards like hl7 and
fire for example
and then through policies I mentioned
destroying data no longer when it's no
longer needed try and do that
automatically where the system can do it
but have policies where it isn't
appropriate network security with Access
Control policies and plenty of system
and data backups of course
so that if any data is lost it isn't for
very long then it can be brought back
so those are
really the key user needs that uh
through much time in this area we've
identified as uh
as really important when it comes to to
putting software systems together that
work really work well on the ground
and I'm just going to spend a bit of
time now uh talking about an nipt
workflow as a as a case study of some of
these aspects
so
I'm going to use the your Gene Flex
modular analysis platform to illustrate
some of those Concepts that we've just
been talking about
the flex analysis platform is
constructed as a set of interconnected
communicated modules they're all those
little boxes uh uh with the gray
background behind all of them
each of them has got a defined boundary
with its neighbors and interfaces for
communications with them but importantly
it looks to the user like worm system
it looks like one
monolithic Software System with one
interface but behind the scenes is
actually built of several modules
um modules are split we have modules
that are split into either customizable
modules or core functions so there are
some core functions that are always
included
um and those are on the left hand side
of that diagram
they might be for example modules that
that split up sequencing data into
multiple samples when it was multiplexed
into one sequencing run
um they could be a frequent fraction
estimator is an important uh QC aspect
of this kind of analysis
alignment to the Genome of course
generally whatever sequencing based
workflow you're using there will need to
be in alignment to a genome whether the
human one or or another genome at some
point to identify where those reads are
absolutely most likely to have come from
so that we can then do the further
processing on them that we need to
that's the case whether you're talking
about a whole genome test or a targeted
methodology
and the customizable modules typically
things like those that calculate the the
final risk score or probability scores
for the test uh those that generate the
report can therefore be modified uh to
suit the local conditions some QC checks
it depends very much on what instruments
you've got and what uh what those are
doing as to where you can where the
points in the data that you can check
against various thresholds to make sure
that everything is working in line
but I'm just going to go into now a
little bit more about these uh and and
talk about how we can meet those needs
to be identified earlier
so the basic steps in an nipt analysis
pipeline
um
what the pipeline ultimately does is it
robustly processes the sequence data
combines it with the patient and Sample
information and output to clinical test
report
and it does that by firstly reading and
filtering the sequence reads mapping
those reads to the genome
of analyzing the DNA location data and
it does that through a number of
statistical model machine learning or AI
based methods and it used and it then
calculates the test results and applies
to QC checks on those just to make sure
that everything is in line and if it
isn't then reject the uh the result and
then finally it generates the test
report which can go back into the the
rest of the system
moving on
Meeting those needs so how do you then
we talked a bit about software safety
and software safety standards before
what you've got to do is explore the
user requirements in full and document
them thoroughly but then operate in
short Sprints that means that you can
then respond to uh slightly changing
user requirements and we we would do run
user panels and show people what the GUI
looks like use wireframes that kind of
thing to get feedback whenever we can
separate the algorithm design from the
software code implementation
um we've got to try and demonstrate
first that science Works 100 on the
bench first so the the analysis actually
does what it's supposed to do before we
go anywhere near writing code for the
application itself test test and test
again uh you I could say test again you
really can't say it enough times
um one software testing methodology is
not enough you've got to do it in small
blocks very close to the coding first
then full modules interconnections of
modules and then finally validate the
whole system
um ideally with samples where we don't
actually know the outcomes until
afterwards
and we just manage the process
throughout so prevent system errors and
failures impacting accuracy and safety
and it's all according to those
standards I mentioned before well one of
them I mentioned 62304 there is also
14971 risk analysis and ISO 13485 for
the overarching quality management
system of course
onto usability
um firstly always consider the customer
requirements or user needs first and
that's clinical or operation and
operational so it is it is talking to
the healthcare professionals it is
talking to the people in the labs who
will use the systems as well fully
consider the wider context and the
environment of the software things like
connectivity come into that
confidentiality
maximize usability overall is the
overall is the message here
which is a key principle for us ease of
use effective systems and integration
and seamless data flow are then what we
need to get out of those
flexibility so it doesn't have to be at
odds with safety with software safety uh
the way that we make sure it isn't at
odds with software safety and that you
can have your cake and eat it
um is the new software deployments used
already developed and pre-verified
medical grade algorithms and software
modules so by developing those modules
individually and testing them
individually as far as possible and risk
analyzing all of their inputs and
outputs individually we can then plug
them together in separate arrangements
and we can develop custom modules if
necessary
to fill needs that maybe the system
doesn't have to begin with
the customizable modules that are
available as well are some for example
some analysis plugins analysis plugins
can be written to implement different
kinds of test algorithms
for example uh to uh to add onto a basic
Trisomy analysis you can add sex
chromosine employee analysis you can add
micro deletions there are various
alternative various alternative tasks
algorithms that we've already
implemented through these plugins and
more can be done
theming plugins to customize the user
experience and make the system look the
way that uh the way that it works best
locally and the way that the local users
wanted to look
um test reporting fully flexible content
and format so that you can have the form
that makes up the report contain what
you want it to contain and where you
want it to put it as well and going
right through to font sizes and where
the logo goes and what ancillary
information goes on it and all that kind
of stuff
and as I mentioned the system can
support fully custom modules if you do
it this way the system can support fully
custom modules if needed to fill in
specific needs
onto connectivity
um so one way of doing this is to build
in a purpose-designed limbs interface
based around a common standard uh hl7
and that defines a standardized language
to communicate both incoming requests
for tests and outgoing requests and test
reports so that's rendered reports or
raw data data fields and I've done a
drawn a very heavily abbreviated version
here just to show you um how the the
connectivity of this could work so we
have another Software System called The
Atlas workflow manager which is it's
kind of I'll talk about it a bit more in
a moment but it's a custom limbs that is
specifically designed to to manage in
detail the kind of test workflows I'm
talking about
uh so the request could come from a a
laboratory limbs into that system by the
hl7 interface uh once the test is
complete
um the flex analysis system can upload
the result with a a copy of the PDF of a
PDF report if necessary as well back to
that limbs again where it can get
Associated back to the original request
uh nobody then has to type anything in
again and nobody has to read something
of one system and type it into another
you don't have uh in interpretation of
forms and then typing back into other
systems which obviously waste a bit of
time and is could be quite error-prone
if you if you address this kind of
connectivity
so Flex has got this purpose design
limbs interface to meet as many of those
connectivity needs as it can
and finally robustness so design QC
checks around the key measurements so
that you can identify when something
goes out of band
uh it allows automated reporting of
workflow and Sample conditions there are
a few examples from nipt here so
typically you would want to measure the
cell free DNA fraction and fail if for
that sample if there is insufficient
signal to call confidently you'd also
want to measure the sequencing output
have we actually got enough reads to
call confidently and very often we would
consider those two things we can trade
those two things off against each other
because it's very important to make the
best use of the information you've got
available so for example if you have a a
really high selfie fetal DNA fraction
you don't actually need as many reads
and you can still get just the same
accuracy out of the system so it's best
to consider those things together
and you can do things like read metrics
from the sequencer so for example the
illuminous systems will sequence a
finance controller recommend that a 5x
controllers is put into every sequencing
we can read the data from that and it
gives you an extra metric that can
identify low quality sequencing output
so that it doesn't then cause a problem
a little bit more about workflow
management that I mentioned before
so the atlas workflow manager is a is a
system that gives full cycle
traceability from bringing a sample into
the results analysis it's like a special
purpose limbs that manages the test very
closely and it integrates the
instruments and Analysis uh into a
virtual workflow
it means you don't need complicated
worksheets and frees up a lot of
operator time it can even tell you when
you put something in the freezer and
where in the freezer it is
um you know for example labels
automatically
um and manage all of the storage of all
of the uh the materials that are part of
the test
and so just to finish off with really
I've got a a few little screenshots that
I've just run through very quickly
firstly on the workflow management front
um it's I know it's not the easiest
thing to read but hopefully you can get
the
a feel for it
um the atlas workflow manager input this
is one of the input screens we have a on
this particular system here we have a a
theme loaded that that makes the system
look a certain way it's using our house
colors here on this page you this is
where you would start receiving a test
order so enter details of the
institution that requested the test uh
some information about patient and
scroll down and add in all of the rest
of the demographic data assuming you
hadn't downloaded it from a lens of
course an external system which you may
have done and then of course you
wouldn't need to type it all in again
here's a a tracking screen so here what
we've got is uh some 16 plasma tubes are
sitting on an instrument we've opened up
the instrument to see what's on it and
it's telling us that there are these 16
tubes and then we've then opened up the
second one and we can see what test that
is for the name of the patient the
institution
and any notes that we might divide it in
we can drill down further into that if
we need to
um on the analysis side finally
on the analysis side uh really just a
front page this one but using a
different theme but uh there is a you
can click through to a test status page
from there or you can click through to
enter sample information assuming it
hasn't come in automatically
um from another system like the workflow
manager or the limbs
there's a little configuration of data
export button in the bottom right there
as well
and then here's one of those test status
pages so it's showing that there are
three tests on the system at the moment
that are going through
um there'd generally be a lot more than
that of course but this is test this is
a software testing data not not real
world data on this particular screen so
it's telling us who the test is for it's
giving us an ID for it and it's got a
button to go through and edit the sample
information create the report and it
tells you what the status through the
workflow is as well
so um
that's pretty much uh
pretty much all of the all that I have
for today uh I've got a a little bit of
a conclusion and a bit of looking
forward as well with a couple of
interesting directions that we can see
that this area is going to go in
so
as a summary software fulfills several
key roles in the NGS workflow whatever
the role there are always going to be
these key needs of robust functionality
safety usability confidentiality
connectivity and flexibility
Flex analysis is a platform from your
Gene for NGS bioinformatics analysis
applications it's a platform so the idea
is you have the core analysis
functionality but there are also these
customizable components that you can
that you can change
and the atlas workflow manager
integrates instruments and Analysis into
a virtual workflow
this is uh what we have here is one way
in which you can you can meet all of
those needs
looking forward
so some interesting things that I see
going on here
um there is there are definitely many
signs of a broader move from one-off
software solutions that do one thing to
much more flexible platforms that can
that can integrate much better with uh
with other lab systems clinical systems
as well but it all still with much with
robust validation so that you have high
confidence in the system and full
Regulatory Compliance including the
software having been developed that way
and um there are some also some
interesting updates coming to the
software regulatory Frameworks
themselves uh there is work going on
that that looks like these standards in
the future will probably reflect more of
an evolution towards Standalone software
software development standard in the
past have mainly been concentrated more
on uh firmware more than software so the
kind of of code that sits inside a
machine
that such as an ultrasound machine for
example less than Standalone software
but there's more of an evolution towards
Standalone software because there's so
much more of it being used
and also the very interesting work going
on to adapt these standards so that we
can bring in more machine learning and
AI techniques uh a pretty difficult
thing to do with the software regulated
software development process as it is
because if a system is learning for
itself how do you validate it
how do you how do you control exactly
what it's doing there are some there is
some guidance now available from the FDA
in in how that can be done and the
European institutes are working on the
same in a similar kind of area it hasn't
made it into the standard just yet but
um but there's a lot of interesting work
going on in that area and we needed to
because we need to bring in the latest
techniques we need to bring in the
latest and most accurate techniques into
medical grade software development
thank you very much for listening